so when you hear word marketing what do
you think about really marketing because
the world of business is a lot about
marketing about how you market yourself
your product what do you think about
what word comes to mind see for me when
I think about the word marketing I think
about how you tell your story how you
tell the story of your company how you
tell the story of yourself how your
story is being told is it reaching the
audience you wanted to reach do you know
the audience that you wanted to reach
that's marketing and a lot of times a
lot of times I remember one time I was
in an audience and I heard this speaker
speaking from stage and its audience was
filled with 70 year olds who are getting
ready to retire there were between 70 to
80 and he's on stage no one in the
audience is less than 55 and he's on
stage and saying can you imagine if one
day you're driving a Ferrari can you
imagine if one day you're driving a
Lamborghini can imagine one day you're
going down to the beach and you're
surfing and I'm sitting there saying
does he know who he's marketing to and
how he's telling the story because your
story doesn't resonate with this
audience maybe it resonates with a
different but does not resonate with
this audience so it is very very
important for you to study marketing and
marketing becomes an art it becomes a
lot of fun if you learn how to do the
proper way it helps you out in business
helps you out going to be aspect to your
life so many of you kept asking me Pat
give me top books I need to read on
marketing and finally we're giving it to
you and I'm giving it to you in a way
where I'll recommend 10 books to you and
then from there you can do whatever you
want with these 10 books I believe every
entrepreneur must study these 10 books
for marketing number 10 for me on this
list would be the art of SEO the art of
SEO is number 10 on the list and the
reason why this was my keep in mind you
can buy this book and I think they have
the most recent addition I don't even
think that's the most recent one Mario I
think there's another edition after this
one yeah there's another dis ascent that
there's another edition after this one
the art of SEO and it's it's pretty big
you're talking about 645 pages and well
you'll first still when you pick this
book up go to the to the content and in
ghost little areas right now you're
struggling with you can literally take
this thing and go to trying SEO
- conversion and ROI I'm struggling with
that let me go study that this almost
becomes the Bible for SEO because
nowadays what you're doing SEO for your
company yourself your site whatever
you're doing you need to understand the
world and the world of SEO if you don't
you're gonna be left behind you your
team your staff needs to know this
language this is the book I would
recommend the next one I would recommend
is contagious contagious is a very good
book that describes the certain elements
combined together that makes up for
something to go viral for something to
spread and the words it uses is social
currency triggers emotion public
practical valiant stories I highly
recommend you read this book contagious
because once you read it you'll kind of
say well now this makes sense why this
idea caught on and it started spreading
I never thought about it this way wonder
stories that talks about in contagious
is the iPhone video right the iPhone he
puts it in the blender and you see this
blender chopping up this phone and this
blender blows up because the point of
this blender was it is so powerful it
can tear up an iphone that is became the
marketing campaign on how to tell the
story of how amazing of a blender this
is this blender started selling blenders
all over all over the world very very
good book to read for marketing is
contagious I'd say the other one is made
to stick I don't know if I have one here
with me we always have one in the office
I don't have one here with me let's put
a picture of it on the video so you can
see it make a stick it's a book that
explains to you how this story sticks
with your audience a lot of times you
will tell a story where somebody will
not remember and then here's what we do
for a company you'll go to presentation
for instance and after presentation you
walk at you remember nothing you don't
member single thing but you'll go to
another presentation same exact topic
same everything the speaker says six
different stories and three of them
stayed with you one of them brought
tears to your eyes and you walk out that
story is made to stick it sticks with
you you will forever link this company
to the story that was shared with you
because it was made to stick it teaches
you how to get your stories to stick
with the people you're doing business
with number seven is traction obviously
traction has
to do with I think it's 19 or 21 points
he talks about in this book on traction
on how to get your concept your product
to start having traction where it starts
creating momentum and starts building on
that momentum very good book traction
number six is trust me online which i
think is one of the best titles out
there for marketing this is by ryan
holiday I think Ryan Holidays trust me
online beautiful title for book and when
you read it he explains to you what
things he did as he was marketing his
products he's got so many great stories
on what he did I would recommend you
reading trust me online number six is
dot-com secrets.com secrets is written
by I want to say his name rod Russell
Branson am I saying the right Russell
Branson and Russell Branson is pretty
well known in the marketing space a lot
of people use and a lot of people know
him and they tame a lot of money to do
the work that he does for them I'm
talking seven figures type of numbers
that this guy gets paid to do the work
in dot-com secrets he simply tells you
how to set up your email he says how to
get the funnels when the customers come
in and how to set up your funnels in a
way that's leading to what you want and
then ask him for more there's a lot of
things you can offer your business
on.com secrets number four to me is
Kotler and Keller marketing management
it's a old-school book that if you go to
university if you get this book you
pretty much no need to go get a
marketing degree because this is what
they talk about the entire time and
marketing it's got so many great stuff
in this book on what you can do on your
marketing side lots of value in this I
was almost putting this as number one
but it's number four
Kotler and Keller and then number three
is tipping point tipping point is what
happened to face book tipping point is
what happened to Instagram to snapchat
tipping point what happened to the
Dollar Shave Club where that one video
which everybody is seen and now Dollar
Shave Club was recently purchased Mario
by who your legislator $4,000,000,000
Dollar Shave Club was just about four
billion dollars after the commercial
went viral on YouTube and got twenty
four million views a billion dollar
check for Dollar Shave Club you'll find
out why that happens in a book tipping
point number two is very close to number
one
I didn't put a number one was
positioning the battle for your mind
it's an older book it's not a newer book
so some of the company's examples it
gives in that book is not newer it's
older but still the book is so effective
and relevant to today that I think every
marketer needs to study that book don't
even read a book that's a book you study
it's called positioning the battle for
your mind there's a lot of different
editions a lot of different colors I
don't know which one you guys going to
put up here on the image to show but
it's a fantastic book for you to read
and then number one obviously above
everything to me in the marketing world
is Blue Ocean Strategy you haven't seen
this in so many different books they've
already sold I don't know three million
copies four million copies every single
market or every CEO I've had every
single executive at one point I had them
read this book cover-to-cover wrote a
paper on it we spend eight hours just
talking about this book in a room full
of 40 people now we were coming up with
ideas after reading this book sometimes
so many people ask me questions about
marketing marque and I asked the
question first read the book blue ocean
strategy then ask me these questions on
marketing this is that important of a
book for every entrepreneur every
businessman every businesswoman every
executive every single person was kind
of planning on doing anything that has
to do with marketing you got to read it
it gives you an edge on business on how
to mark it and tell your story in a
unique way where you separate yourself
from all the other competitors
everyone's trying to go up to one market
you pivot and all of a sudden you don't
have an enemy anymore and you have an
easier time getting a bigger piece of
this pie because then there's no enemies
enemies it's a water
it's a you're you're in a blue ocean
where there's no one there instead of a
red ocean shark infested you're in a
beautiful place over here okay those are
the ten books I will recommend you to
read on marketing and if you've read any
of them comment on the bottom if you
suggest any other marketing books I'm
always looking for good marketing books
I've read most of them but if there are
any good marketing books recommend those
books on the bottom if you haven't
subscribed to this channel yet if you
haven't subscribed to this channel yet
our goal is to get 2 million subs by the
end of the year be sure to subscribe to
the channel here I think right here
somewhere here and enjoin a notification
squad as well and with that being said
for watching everybody take care about
[Music]